PEOPLE NEED HELP.
FASCINATING, GREAT SHOW AS
ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" TONIGHT.
MAJOR NEW ENDORSEMENTS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ALEXANDERALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTE
MY DREAM IN YOUR TAXES THROUGH
THE ROOF.
BERNIE SANDERS HEAPING MASSIVE
PRAISE ON JOE BIDEN’S HARD LEFT
TURN, AND BERNIE ADMITTING THAT
BIDEN IS NOW A RADICAL SOCIALIST
LIKE HIM.
WE HAVE A MINI MONOLOGUE COMING
UP ON THAT AND SO MUCH MORE.
FIRST, OUR TOP STORY TAKES US TO
PORTLAND, OREGON.
ANOTHER LIBERAL CITY RUN BY
LIBERALS FOR DECADES.
UNLAWFUL, VIOLENT RIOTS ARE
TURNING THE CITY INTO A LITERAL
DISASTER AREA AND YEAH, IT LOOKS
LIKE A WAR ZONE LIKE OTHER
PLACES.
FOR MONTHS, PORTLAND HAS BEEN
RIPPED APART BY SOCIALIST
ANARCHISTS.
THREE COURTHOUSES HAVE NOT BEEN
DAMAGED ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
THE HATFIELD COURTHOUSE WAS
FIREBOMBED.
THE U.S. CUSTOM HOUSE WAS
VANDALIZED.
POLICE WERE ATTACKED WITH
LASERS.
SEVERAL OFFICERS NOW ASSAULTED
WITH A SLEDGEHAMMER’S.
STORES WERE BROKEN INTO,
BUILDINGS WERE SET ON FIRE.
THIS IS INSANE.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF ASSAULT, ARSON,
GRAFFITI, LOOTING, VANDALISM,
VIOLENCE, YOU NAME IT.
SO-CALLED DEMONSTRATORS EVEN
ATTEMPTING TO SET UP THEIR OWN
AUTONOMOUS ZONE JUST LIKE THE
CHOP, CHAS, SUMMER OF LOVE,
SPAGHETTI POTLUCK DINNER ZONE OF
SEATTLE AND SO FAR BUSINESSES IN
THE DOWNTOWN AREA OF PORTLAND
HAVE REPORTED AT LEAST
$23 MILLION IN FINANCIAL LOSSES.
HERE’S A SMALL SAMPLE OF WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE THERE ON A DAILY
BASIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> STAY OUT OF THE STREET.
ON THE SIDEWALK.
[BLEEP] [SOUND OF EXPLOSIONS]
[INDISCERNIBLE
[INDISCERNIBLE SHOUTING]
>> Sean: THIS HAS NOW BEEN
GOING ON FOR MORE THAN SIX
STRAIGHT WEEKS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
12 DEAD POLICE OFFICERS, 1200
INJURED AND ROCKS AND BRICKS AND
BOTTLES AND MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
WANT TO BE A COP IN PORTLAND
TONIGHT?
NOT ONLY ARE PORTLAND’S FAR LEFT
CITY LEADERS LETTING THIS
HAPPEN, THERE ACTIVELY SHUTTING
ANY AND ALL HELP FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP, JUST LIKE
SEATTLE, JUST LIKE CHICAGO AND
JUST LIKE NEW YORK.
HOW HAVE THINGS WORKED OUT IN
THOSE THREE LIBERAL-RUN CITIES
FOR DECADES?
IN FACT, WHEN THE DHS EMPLOYED
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TO
PROTECT THE CITY’S FEDERAL
BUILDINGS, THEY WERE ACCUSED OF
"ACTING LIKE AN OCCUPYING ARMY."
TED WHEELER DEMANDED THE FEDERAL
AGENTS "FOLLOW LOCAL RULES, ALL
WHILE RIOTERS WERE ACTING WITH
IMPUNITY.
HE WENT ON TO THEN TWEET.
THE BEST THING THEY CAN DO IS
STAY INSIDE THEIR BUILDING OR
LEAVE PORTLAND ALTOGETHER, AND